again mr. branimir yeah he recently
totally killed me in this in this
opening the very soft that was a really
tough loss damn ok I know he's playing
differently when f3 last time ok here
normally do this ok so everything's he
seems to is all theory or what seems to
be really really playing quickly
okay so I have got a double fianchetto
but why there's a very very fluent quick
development so it should be maybe that's
equal or something something like that
yeah he has this pressure on e 7 that's
quite quite a nuisance so maybe age 6
here yeah I think I amateur force this
away
Jeff
okay I actually thought pawn takes
sometimes could be interesting but that
doesn't seem necessary him
Wow
wait why is he giving that up I don't
get it giving me the better minor piece
just like that okay so we'll just drop
the eighth
yeah black has a slight advantage in
bishop stronger than the night my queen
on d5 is well placed this is even more
more important looking at a two for
example so he cannot so easily move his
rook and okay yep is 96 but right still
upon so let's take have F up t seven
that'd be to us at the end it's the pawn
that I can take at the end only thing
that I don't like I have two looks
unprotected sometimes this can be costly
then he actually might take so shouldn't
do that I maybe h5 him that's probably
good g4 I can still go back to d5 if he
goes chief form
hmm so i can take on between aura that's
not illegal or anything let's do that
check
if you have this combination of a bishop
on the long diagonal and an ape on that
looks like it's supposed to oh it's it's
about to start running it's very often
worth some some things am looks looks
quite quite dangerous this a pond it's
not if this is this is a dangerous move
most definitely Heydrich hangs 95 is
possibly in okay I'm moving this look
away 95 yeah I wonder if I should take
that twice and just set my hopes on the
a porn
we're just like rook t6 or something
difficult camp come on does he heaven
group move it might not be enough to win
actually if I do that but who came
the night is such a such an annoying
piece and blitz chess
my rook is still unprotected but I don't
see any discovered a check that is of
any significance like rookie to teaching
rook a for maybe ran rogue f5
okay spending some time there looked you
toward
looking at H floor as well so what is it
doing they are going for maybe some rock
d 7 or something and then what Queen d5
Queen to f5 maybe 25
time warning check trading this very
difficult to do
if one takes a three he just about saves
himself so be five
now you have to have to protect that in
the first place Jack jump or to shame
them what a shame
and that only thought I should win this
somehow but couldn't really make it work
check your play the same time DRA our
third check black yeah my fix hand thank
you i love those people you're always
writing thank you after they just
completely undeservedly one on time but
okay it's weird that it wasn't a win I
mean it was a win certainly here with
the right play but i don't know maybe
not a win but if anybody wins it's black
of course check Remmy 2 H we are this
was this was the wrong decision between
f5 I really have miscounted actually
with the pawn but probably his counter
players is good enough that's possible
to hold this yeah I can't cover this but
that's probably the comp gives 000 and
well this is a complete this is just
total calculation so the compass
definitely write down okay Quinn b5
keeping the keeping the rukon I thought
work the torso only move yeah okay that
the real thing is probably that i am not
sure if i have to take them check check
is just just to draw of course but ok
it's it's this time control what can you
do who ok thanks for watching